welcome my name is Jim Neal I'm the
university librarian at Columbia
University and we are the sponsor the
Friends of the library of this event
this evening please consider joining the
friends it enables us to put on events
like this and it also helps us to make
the libraries of Columbia and the work
of our faculty and students so much
better through your support this event
is built as Robert K Merton at 100
reflections and recollections we've
invited a very distinguished panel of
individuals who have known and worked
with dr. Merton and will reflect this
evening on their experiences with mr.
Merton a scholar teacher mentor and
colleague we do this tonight because we
have just completed the processing of
the Robert Merton papers which were
contributed to the libraries at Columbia
University and are available through the
Rare Book and Manuscript library in
Butler library we also chose to do it
now because it is the hundredth
anniversary of Robert Norton's birth and
it seemed the appropriate time that
confluence of events for us to celebrate
that extraordinary career after
tonight's panel discussion and your
opportunity to raise some questions and
share come on some comments we're going
to ask you to consider walking briefly
across campus to the butler library
where we will have a reception in the
Rare Book and Manuscript library which
is on the sixth floor above there also
is an exhibit drawn from the Robert
Merton collection so you'll have an
opportunity to see some of the wonderful
materials that will be available for
scholarship I would also add that we
have a fantastic exhibit on the work of
Joseph urban as well and I think you
will find that extremely exciting and
interesting it was reported and
celebrated in the New York Times so it's
gotten a lot of recognition I'd like to
introduce Harriet Zukerman Harriet will
serve as the host and convener and
speaker Lee
speaker at this panel this evening she
is the professor emeritus of Columbia
University and most recently senior vice
president of the mellon Foundation I was
amazed when I reached into the Mellon
website and I found when it noted her
her retirement that over the her career
at at mellon foundation she joined in
1991 she have been responsible for 1,400
grants to 206 organizations representing
775 million dollars of extraordinary
investment in the work of higher
education and the work of research and
scholarship before joining the
foundation she was professor of
sociology here at Columbia where she
chaired the department from 78 to 82 she
received her AP from Vassar and her PhD
from Columbia as we know her research
has focused on the social organization
of science and scholarship her books and
her journal papers are extraordinary
I would note her authorship of
scientific elite Nobel laureates in the
United States and her Coweta ship of
another volume of the outer circle women
in the scientific community earlier this
year we invited her to come to Columbia
to speak about an important book she had
co-authored with Princeton University
Press
educating scholars doctoral education in
the humanities
she's a trustee of the Center for
Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences on the board of directors of
the American Association for the
Advancement of science and the Social
Sciences Research Council she's a member
of the American Philosophical Society
and the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences we are thankful to Harriet for
making Robert mertens papers available
to the students and scholars and to
researchers from around the world and we
are very appreciative for her
willingness to join us tonight to offer
the opening talk and to convene the
panel Harry
I didn't imagine there would be an
obstacle course to guess here when
Michael Ryan who is the director of the
rare books and manuscripts library and
Jim Neil who you have just heard who is
Columbia's chief librarian broached the
possibility to me of a celebration a
joint celebration of the opening of what
those who look at it will see is a truly
elegant professional organized archive
and the hundredth anniversary of Bob's
death how could I not agree and agree so
quickly that I think I must have shocked
them it was clear from the outset that
this was not to be an occasion for
critical assessment of Bob's work
conferences here and abroad have been
held for that purpose and a spate of
books have been published on his work
one just out which is sitting in
professor professor Stabler and one
about to appear Michael and I thought
instead what we might do was with a very
gentle suggestion to this speakers who
we would not dream of telling what to
say that they might focus on the aspect
of bug the man and the thinker that was
less visible to people not exactly the
private Merton but the not so public
Merton well each of these speakers will
of course say what he wants to say but
and my job as Jim Neil said is to
introduce the speakers to try to keep
some order among them and then I
I will not start the occasion now I will
and therefore introduce the speakers in
order beginning with he is Adams
University professor of history emeritus
and James Duncan Phillips professor of
early American history emeritus at
Harvard for decades now but Baylin has
been a Doyen of American history his
multiple Pulitzer Prizes its Bancroft
prize his National Book Award and more
honorary degrees than I could even
recite before we all had to go home a
testing of standing though I have to say
I was especially pleased but as I told
you that Columbia conferred an honorary
Doctor of Letters no bud and I have to
say there's no disrespect that I call
him bud all his friends do is literally
a member of the family
he married Mladic who I know it's here I
saw her come in who is of course the
daughter of paul lazarsfeld
and mitzi Jahoda who what paul being
bob's closest friend and longest
collaborator and fellow builder of
columbia sociology but it's not only the
academic and the familial ties that bind
us here to bud he has a special place in
the Mert own Ian story for having served
as the unwitting inspiration a Bob's
favorite book on the shoulders of giants
yeah thanks well it's an honor to be
here to say just a few words about Bob
Merton I will refer to these people by
their first names as Harriet just said
my connection is a little personal in
the way she described but I have to say
to begin with that my encounters with
Bob Merton have always been rather
dramatic there's something dramatic
about all of these encounters and they
began very early years and years and
years ago when I was a graduate student
and believe me that was a long time ago
I had become engaged to Lottie
glasersfeld as Harriet has said and paul
lazarsfeld was even then a very very
close collaborator with Bob Merton
there were great friends they saw each
other continuously in the Department of
Sociology and in the Bureau of applied
Social Research and it was therefore
incumbent upon Paul to present his
prospective son-in-law to Bob Merton and
so it was arranged that I was presented
I was presented to the Mertens who were
very kind and invited us to dinner at
their house
on Hastings on Hudson lottie's mother
was in town she was then professor of
psychology at NYU and so it was arranged
Lonnie and I were staying with her
mother on her apartment on Fifth Avenue
and 8th Street
and so it was arranged I had my car and
we picked up Mitzi and she was called
and Lottie and we drove up to West 86th
Street and picked Paul up and drove out
to Hastings on the highway now you have
to understand I was quite apprehensive
about this Bob Merton was already a
famous man and I knew Paul's great
friendship for him and this was becoming
quite a delicate affair and I thought a
good deal about this and I did a little
homework and I read some of Bob Merton
stuff and I got a better sense of his
interest and I said to myself I better I
better develop some ideas appropriate to
this occasion and so I did and I got up
some quite clever formulations I may say
and as we drove along the highway I
worked out some very elegant things that
I might toss casually in to the
conversation and it was going along fine
and then a catastrophe happened we ran
out of gas
and I remember vividly the four of us
there sitting in silent disbelief that
such a stupid thing could have happened
but I made the most of it and there was
a gas station fairly near so I got out
and I got a can of gas and I got the car
started and but then I have to tell you
I had run out of gas not only physically
but emotionally at that point and also
intellectually and by the time we got to
Hastings to the Mertens about a 3/4 of
an hour late I was completely out of gas
and I have blanked out completely on
that dinner I have no recollection
whatever of what happened I've repressed
the entire thing that was my first
encounter with Bob Merton but he was a
very generous man and he had a great
interest in the history I was doing
which was 17th century history which he
had written his dissertation on and we
got along fine and he was a generous man
and we struck up a correspondence that
went on for some years and he was
interested in what I was doing I sent
him manuscripts he responded very kindly
he wrote notes on them wonderful notes
directed me into areas I would never
have dreamed of and it was already very
it was really of an exceptionally
interesting relationship that we had
largely by mail until 1959 in 1959 Bob
sent me a copy of his presidential
address to the American Sociological
Association it was an extremely elegant
as some of you know address and in it he
referred to Newton's reference to that
phrase that we are dwarfs seated on the
shoulder
of giants and therefore can see farther
than they and in responding to the offer
and he sent me I wrote him a short note
which I have with me which is dated
November 8th 59 in which I commented on
this saying that he attributes to Newton
and said that in my study of medieval
French history I had found that that was
referred to by Bernardo chart in the
early 12th century this was in the end
of 1959 a year later I got a letter from
Bob in which he said that my little note
had touched off his thinking on this
subject on which he had been collecting
materials since 1942 and he decided to
write an answer to my letter which he
had begun in Christmas 1959 and he never
finished it but he said well he'll send
it anyway this was a year later it had
been sitting around he said he's never
going to finish this so he sent it to me
and I have it here it is add it out form
this letter of 44 single spaced pages it
is twenty thousand words it is the most
erudite work of scholarship I had ever
seen in my life and it has all of the
references that I've ever been made in
the whole of Western culture to this
aphorism and I have this purple
duplicate of that he sent me which is a
precious item in my
archive and then I had the problem of
trying to figure out how to respond to
this letter I was afraid if I sent him
another little letter god knows what I'd
get so instead I tried a little Chandi
and trick of my own and wrote him a
rather limping letter considering the
ways in which if I were to have answered
that letter I might have done so this
was a little pale next what I had
received but it was the best I could do
I then said that I was very much
interested in this particularly because
of my interest in Laurence Sterne the
tristram shandy book was written by
Laurence Sterne had I had a senior year
in college which I never did I would
have written my honors thesis on
Laurence Sterne and I explained in this
letter why I had switched to history in
thinking about Stern and his books and
Bob wrote me back another very
thoughtful I thank God it was not that
long but a very interesting letter in
the ways in which people find themselves
within the intellectual world and I had
found myself in history and he wrote me
a short discourse on how people do this
and it is a lovely letter I must say in
response to me at the bottom of which he
said people have suggested that he
published the letter he sent me as an
essay and what did I think about that so
I wrote back and I said I think it's
great
publish it and put it in with your other
essays only not with the personal stuff
without the salutations in other words
without me things were quiet for four
years and then in 1965 I got another
package from Bob Merton this time the
published book and there it is that
great book on the shoulders at SOG as he
referred to it
shoulders of giants and to my horror but
then mix pride he had put my letter in
it and I couldn't I couldn't figure out
and I have to confess to you I still
haven't figured out whether that was a
good thing or a bad thing and I didn't
know whether take pride in it or be
embarrassed but in any case it is all
there in this fabulous book rambling on
about the universe of that aphorism
throughout the whole of Western culture
and it is a stunning book as I say
everything with Merton was dramatic but
to turn more seriously about about him I
have to say that I always thought of him
in tandem because I saw him of course
with Paul all the time otherwise I would
not have known him at all and I saw the
two of these people working together and
I have to tell you they're never in
human history has there been a more Odd
Couple paul lazarsfeld was central
europe he was the second V Newark Rice
he was fluent and gregarious in three
languages equally well he was the
epitome of a middle European gentleman
he was voluble he was excitable he was
all over the place and he was a academic
operator such as I had never seen one of
his colleagues said that paul lazarsfeld
thinks the way to buy a postage stamp is
to fly to Washington and cut a deal with
a Postmaster General you know that was
an merton was the exact opposite he was
cool he was collected he was just as
witty but in an entirely different way
and the two of them worked together to
develop in tandem these two
utterly different people the most
creative Institute in social research I
think that existed at the time the
Bureau of applied Social Research funded
by the grants of Paul could get in
elevated to the level of sophistication
that Bob could give it was one of the
great nurseries of scholarship of the
post-war period it was a great
accomplishment I can't go into it some
of you probably worked in the bureau at
one point or know something about it it
was a marvelous accomplishment and the
two of them worked together but the
thing that struck me I think most about
their relationship which was so that
consistent over so many years was the
respect they had for each other they
were very different people I cannot
imagine that they went through these
years of collaboration without conflict
they must have but I wasn't aware of it
I was impressed especially by the
respect they had for each other which
they documented each wrote a memoir of
the other Paul wrote a long and
fascinating essay called working with
Burton in the Festschrift from Merton
and it is a book it is an essay really
worth studying and Merton wrote a piece
not quite as long but equally discerning
on Paul after he died in a memorial book
and the two of them the respect they had
for each other and their sense of each
other's qualities come out in those
memoirs superbly well Paul ended his and
I'll end this with a similar point was
not a literary type and his prose was
half of it was dictated he had no sense
Merton had a marvelous sense of language
and of the uses of English Paul didn't
but on this occasion at the end
Paul did in describing Merton as an
intellectual did move into a more
literary phase in the following way
he said that Merton was very displeased
with the way people were treating
concepts they didn't know how to deal
with concepts they were clumsy and they
were rough in handy they tagged them
they gave my name they put it on a shelf
this was concept X but they didn't
really know what to do with a concept
Merton Paul said approach the concept as
an expert approaches a precious gem and
examines its exterior qualities its
shape its coloration the refraction it
gets from concepts that are adjacent to
it and the way in which overall the
intellectual heft of it can be
understood and then can find a fault
line which he can track and find within
it the interior qualities of the gem now
the aspects of mertens intellectual life
are so vast I couldn't begin to touch on
that even if I knew enough but that does
seem to me to encapsulate the superb
qualities that he had and that buzzers
felt I think so wonderfully responded to
thank you
we turn now to Jonathan Cole jonathan is
Columbia's former provost and Dean of
faculties and now the John Mitchell
Mason professor of the University he
began this illustrious career as Bob
student he became his dear friend and he
was with a group of us promoters of the
sociology of science he was the author
of landmark studies both by himself and
with others and I was one of those
others for example on social
stratification and science women and
science
you Jim attributed that book to me it is
the the outer circle is as much John's
work as mine and he struck out on his
own to study legal decision-making
most recently no doubt because of his
stint long stint as Provost he became
very much concerned with the place of
American universities in the society in
which we live his book that was
published last year the great American
research university has been reviewed
here and abroad and it is certainly
clear to me that whenever people now get
together to talk about research
universities and their problems
Jonathan's book is at the center of the
discussion it is definitive and it's
definitive in that it's a statement
either to be agreed with or argued with
which it has been or both
Thank You Harriet I'm delighted to be
here this evening to celebrate this
important intellectual event in the
history of Columbia University the
official celebration of the opening of
the Robert K Merton archives thanks to
my dear friend and colleague of many
years Harriet Zukerman as well as to the
brilliant work of the people at the rare
books in manuscript library at Columbia
a treasure is opened to the world today
for those who knew Bob well and admired
his intellectual practices in style we
knew that he was fond of the term
truffle dogging he admired those who had
a nose for a good problem could sniff it
out and bring it to life with clarity
and depth he was of course an
extraordinary editor and correspondent
to truffle dog himself as well as a
prolific writer of drafts of manuscripts
not always published and of teaching
notes he was a collector and connoisseur
of scholarly works and was
simultaneously organized a new
assignment sannyasin organized
sufficiently well to color code file
material which he would squirrel away
only to be able to retrieve them years
later for the relevant showing and
telling those who use these archives
will find almost unlimited amounts of
unique material and information about
him his work his acquaintances his role
as minence Grise and as much about the
the age in which he lived which spanned
a good deal of the 20th century it will
sustain and amuse and add enormous Lee
to the scholarly work of hundreds of
those who visit and use this collection
I understand that my assignment tonight
is not to focus principally on the
substantive work of Merton that most of
you here are familiar with but to
provide some limited insight into the
other Merton the aspects of this man
that was not visible to everyone that
they might not fully appreciate I shall
try to stick to that assignment but I
can't refrain from talking about one
serious sociological matter that I
believe is linked to Merton but that has
not yet been well explored Robert Merton
was of course a giant among twentieth
century social scientists not only
sociologists both in print and in person
he had a profound influence on modern
social science and particularly in the
study of bureaucracy deviance mass
communications social stratification and
the sociology of knowledge and of
science he created an American style of
sociological inquiry theories of the
middle range that a link theory is
closely with empirical testing it's what
made really his relationship with Paul
so extraordinary Paul wanted to be the
theorist and he wanted to be the
empirical researcher turned out they
were the opposite of course he was a
consummate essayist and a lover of
language and he used it with such grace
tact and analytic precision that many of
the terms he coins have a deceptively
self-evident clarity and have passed
into common usage I am thinking of
course of the focus-group the Matthew
effect the perspective of the insider an
outsider and the self-fulfilling
prophecy the magic of Robert Merton
reached audiences beyond sociology his
students populated the leading
departments of sociology for several
generations and as larger influence was
felt not only by historians of science
economists political theorists and
anthropologists but also made its way
across disciplinary boundaries into the
worlds of the sciences humanities and
law despite his seminal contributions to
many areas of sociological knowledge
Robert Merton his first scholarly love
was the historical and sociological
study of science he was the father of
the discipline
his science technology in society of
17th century England originally Pyrus
which was the 1938 published version of
his Harvard doctoral dissertation is
almost certainly the most important
sociological study ever produced in
August 1958 after 20 years spent
cultivating other fields Merton
announced his return to the study of
science in his renowned presidential
address at the American Sociological
Association a talk entitled priorities
of scientific discovery which professor
Balin alluded to many subsequent studies
of the social system of science of the
ethos of science and of the theoretical
basis of conflicts over scientific
priority followed from the ideas
presented in that extraordinary address
for the next 30 years Merton and his
students developed and legitimated the
study of science as a social institution
although mertens work touched on many
disparate subjects common theoretical
elements and strategies knit them
together into a highly coherent body of
work whether focusing on the political
machine or on the priority dispute
between newton and leibniz of the
invention of the calculus Merton
examined the ways in which social
structures constrain and direct the
choices of individuals and the way in
which in turn their choices had
institutional consequences why was it so
difficult to root out the political
machine how did the emphasis on
originality in science lead to deviance
among scientists Merton often found
solutions by going at the problem from
an odd angle by turning away from
received wisdom and from the language in
which it was enshrined he looked at the
unintended consequences of actions such
as the way in which the ESO ethos of
Puritanism led to the growth of science
in 17th century England Merton naturally
gravitated towards irony and paradox in
his famous paper social structure in
anomie he shows an American
the desire to succeed to get ahead
creates an American vice deviant
behavior he analyzed the ways in which
political bosses do more good with less
justice than the just government does
when it fails to fulfill the social
needs of people who are unable to
navigate complex government
bureaucracies in the ironies of the
unintended consequences of pattern
behavior Merton found the magic the
material that was there but could not be
seen immediately by most observers an
explanatory magic that was not revealed
to the reader until Bob was ready to
pull the rabbit out of the hat to begin
to understand Bob you had to accept the
idea that the power of personality can
be almost as influential as the power of
intellect Merton was not only a
transcendent mind but also a life force
he was a mesmerizing classroom teacher a
magician in front of would-be
prestidigitators he came to Nova I came
to know Bob Merton as my teacher in the
mid-1960s first as an undergraduate
auditor of one of his famous courses
analysis of social structures that was
offered annually to over 150 students
the content of the course was often
original from year to year in it Merton
taught more Tony in theory that is he
taught himself the dramatic tension of
our km's classes was palpable we
witnessed the genesis the evolution and
sometimes the extinction of ideas
concepts of social structure were
chiseled out smooth Dover and used as
building blocks for larger theories of
social structure little of this material
could be found in his or other published
work but I believe they were found in
the archive there were dramatic
reversals and any amounts disasters and
triumphs as students took stock and try
to establish their own identities
through critical analyses of these
Bertoni ins mattone Ian isms I should
say
we watched someone with the skill of
Bobby Fischer toying with a Boris
Spassky
we tried to follow along and anticipate
the next six moves but most often Merton
seemed Magisterial to his students
whether they were his own students or
those who had drifted in from other
social science disciplines they were in
awe of him and often scared of
disappointing him a few years later when
I was his teaching assistant it occurred
to me and to others of the students and
Merton seemed in fact larger than life
consistent with my training I tested
that hypothesis in a survey of students
of that course analysis of social
structures over 150 responded to the
question how tall is Robert K Merton I
there was a little variance in opinion
the class average had Merton at six foot
three and an and a half inches in height
a full two inches taller than he
actually was it was true Merton was in
fact larger than life Merton recruited
me to graduate school in 1964 and early
on I was fortunate to work with him as a
research and teaching assistant he had
an extraordinary critical eye and
sensibility and he was as I noted
earlier a meticulous editor of
manuscripts nothing got past him
sometimes I tried but nothing got past
him I once misused the word stipend in a
draft of a paper I was writing I
experienced then what a generation of
leading sociologists had before me there
Merton read editorial pen and later his
prolific use of stamps each of which
conveyed a substantive measured message
sociology was fortunate that it had its
Robert Merton who understood so well
that clear elegant thought goes
hand-in-hand with clear elegant language
and who led by the example in his essays
as well as in his brilliant digressive
satire of learning on the shoulders of
giants
this was especially so in mid-century
when sociological jargon appeared
regularly for ridicule in magazines like
the New Yorker
when Bob found my stipend error and it
surely was not the only one that he
identified over the years he gave me a
handwritten memo many pages long on the
etymology and various correct uses of
the word stipend
now that Bob's papers are available in
the rare books and manuscripts
collection at Columbia University
researchers will find out how much of
mertens editing helped shape the
arguments of many of the best works of
sociology produced by his students and
others over several generations but
something more needs to be done to flesh
out Merton as editor there needs to be
an all-points bulletin put out too many
people who benefited and were subjected
to the Merton read editorial pen we must
ask them to send the Columbia library
examples of those editorial jobs that he
did on their manuscripts that they still
possess if bob was tough on his students
he was tougher on himself nothing left
his hands for publication until his own
high standards were met often years
would pass before Bob release papers for
publications sometimes reducing rather
than enhancing the impact of these
papers comparing the various drafts of
his own work would prove of great value
and would answer the question of whether
in the quest for perfect formulations
you could lose the moment of the impact
in conveying an important idea to the
professional and larger communities of
course Bob was not without his foibles
Bob had his moods that seemed to be
related to how well his writing was
going writing that he began religiously
about 6:00 a.m. every morning after
class conversations about his ideas or
mine
they were always intense but they were
more or less rewarding depending up
on how bob was feeling now after a while
I discovered that Bob had is good poker
players say a tell in those days Bob
smoked both the pipe and cigars
after many experimental trials and I
mean many I learned that when Bob was
smoking a pipe he was accessible I could
knock on his door and wind up spending a
wonderful hour talking to him
however if Bob were smoking a cigar I
would never knock on his door but
instead do a fast about-face and walk
quickly and quietly out of 415 fairway
the Hall as my relationship with Bobby
evolved into friendship he continued to
teach me his instruction was
multi-dimensional when Joanna and I were
young married he advised us not to put
our scarce dollars into works of current
fiction but instead to by reference
books over the years books have come and
gone in our house but as Bob predicted
the multi-volume OAD and the DMB
Strong's biblical concordance and many
other reference works have happily
remained thanks to that good advice from
a good friend today of course all of
that is easily accessible through the
internet Bob's teaching in other areas
was equally wise he was after all who
taught me the person who taught me the
inestimable and transcendent value a
very good single malt scotch
and nothing of interest escaped Bob's
critical eye when Joanna and I became
part of his extended family we would
watch Nick games together Bob would
apply his analytical skills to breaking
down opponent defenses and what
occasionally jump out of his seat much
to my surprise and frustration at a
particularly stupid play by Walt Clyde
Frazier or dick Barnett to great Nick
back back core players over all these
years in ways too numerous to count and
to various to enumerate Bob and Harriet
have always been ready
and supremely able to give good and
disinterested counsel it's a debt that
cannot be repaid and it continued well
into the years when I was Provost at
Columbia the last time Bob and Harriet
came over for a family dinner my 24 year
old daughter nonny
a doctoral student in art history at
Columbia joined us Bob and nonny were
old friends and had corresponded a bit
when she was at college and needed some
advice about independent multiple
discoveries that evening Bob at 92 still
standing tall and straight had lost some
of his physical energy but not one iota
of mental acuity and quite frankly the
presence of a beautiful young woman
seemed to energize him with Bob in the
lead he and nonny began talking about
the possibility of analyzing the history
of art in terms of the social
organization of artists Bob delineating
delineated three lines of inquiry that
might prove fruitful he expounded on
each of them and took nonny and the rest
of us on a scholarly journal journey
replete with lengthy lengthy detours
afterwards nonny told us that she was
always amazed and delighted when Bob
after long excursions and parentheses
finally wove the various strands of his
arguments coherently together and so yet
another generation had fallen under the
spell of the Mert own Ian magic I want
to turn for just a moment to a more
serious sociological point as he often
did bob was able to capture a concept in
a phrase he originated the idea of
obliteration through incorporation which
can be found in his 1949 set of essays
social theory and social structure or
the idea that the origins of ideas are
often lost because their content is
assimilated into the general literature
and the original author is no longer
referenced when talked at Parsons
actually
quoted Krane Britain at the beginning of
the structure of social action saying
who reads Herbert Spencer today he was
referring to a school of thought that
had been influential but largely
rejected if I ask who reads Merton today
I can answer positively that many
scholars if not mostly sociologists
still references work on the Matthew
effect in science social structure
Anatomy principles of scientific
discovery and the unanticipated
consequences of purpose of social action
Merton continues to be referenced
significantly I did account this past
month of the citations to his work in
the web of science and found that his
work was cited fully 248 times in 2010
topping the 222 times a year earlier so
his work continues to have a substantial
impact but much of Bob's best work has
not in fact been developed and I don't
think that it is because it has been
obliterated through incorporation it
seems to me that there is a parallel
concept to obliteration through
incorporation which we might call
obliteration without incorporation now
most ideas have little lasting value and
ought to be tossed away without
incorporation most published ideas are
never cited and have no impact within
their own lifetime some ideas are
resisted because they are premature
before their time and are poorly
understood by the scientific community I
would count some of Barbara McClintock's
ideas about jumping genes or transposons
or Stanley prisoners ideas about prions
or proteins as a cause for disease upon
these premature or resisted ideas these
ideas are either eventually rediscovered
and elaborated on or by sheer force the
will persistence and additional hard
work by scientists earn their stripes in
the larger community Merton was of
course interested in this phenomena of
resistance by scientists
to scientific discovery but I am
suggesting something different here I'm
suggesting that there are some portions
of the body of work of very substantial
thinkers that are tossed away for no
good reason
there are many original ideas that
become lost artifacts of an intellectual
age which one ought to dig up and see if
they are worth pursuing
if not then let them rest in peace few
ideas actually stand the test of time or
even become obliterated through
incorporation but some are potentially
powerful and are lost in the shift of
paradigms never to be retrieved except
by historians of ancient works many
ideas of one generation of scholars
which have not been rejected empirically
or otherwise by the next generation or
two but that have still have great
potential for elaboration of lost in the
ether today for example Merton did
extraordinary work on aspects of social
structure that are largely ignored today
without having been elaborated on tested
empirically or found to be logically
flawed that seems to me unfortunate and
yet we know very little about why this
happens perhaps the work of Bob Merton a
hundred years after his birth can become
a case study for the study of the
rebirth of ideas thank you
I can only say that the person who is
being described here is being described
with remarkable consistency the comments
Jonathan and bud have made dovetail
perfectly with my own now I will
discover whether Richard Senate's
dovetail perfectly with my own Richard
Sennett his University professor of the
humanities at NYU and Centennial
professor sociology at the London School
of Economics unlike the rest of the
speakers
he has never been bob student never his
co-author never a fellow department
member or had some shared organizational
responsibility like Bob Richard defies
location in the organization of
disciplines by preference he is not a
member of a particular discipline he's
not simply a sociologist or historian or
a philosopher or a specialist in urban
life but his own combination of these
and I must say other specializations as
well
his first book dealt with family
structure and social mobility in 19th
century Chicago then came a quartet of
books which examined her urban culture
then a trilogy of books on welfare and
social class his flesh and stone' which
is a terrific title explored how beliefs
about hit the human body shaped the
design of cities lest I remind you that
when we talk about moving about cities
we talk about arteries and veins most
recently he's been working on a series
of books on the material practices of
culture
Richard will tell me whether it the book
on craftsmanship craftsman is their most
recent or the next most reason the most
recent it's a marvelous book it deals
with the human impulse that is universal
and enduring the desire to do a job well
his analyses take him to such diverse
domains as architecture the building of
violins Richard as a cellist and Linux
software Bob read all of Richard's work
attentively and he greatly enjoyed their
talks Richard
I'm really going to just offer you a
brief footnote about Bob's place in New
York intellectual life as I saw it seems
in a way odd to celebrate celebrate Bob
Merton centenary since he was always
present to me has always been present to
me is at first knew him forty years ago
in the fullness of his middle age and
full of life as Harriet mentioned I was
never his student and knew him as New
Yorkers did then through at first chance
encounters in the rather tight small
circle of what was then called the New
York intellectuals this included his
Columbia colleagues Lionel trilling and
Mayer Shapiro bob was part of it and not
part of it and it's that doubleness an
insider who also had a critical distance
to be an outsider which seems to me to
be a kind of hallmark of his public life
in in New York I should say about what
are called the New York intellectuals
that this was a remarkably incestuous
group of people who were struggling with
a trauma which is the relationship of
Marxism political practice to modernism
in culture and this was not Bob's trauma
this was not something that kept him
awake at night as it did Lionel trilling
or Daniel Bell
he was friends with that original
generation with the generation that
followed it which was my generation and
his attitude was one of I would say a
kind of amused irony something that in
this incestuous family was obliterated
it was a non it gave him distance but he
also through this amused irony was
telling the people who were in this
family that they had perhaps to look at
themselves as though they also were
Outsiders Bobbitt asked me when we first
met since I just started toiling in the
academic vineyard what kind of career do
you want in sociology and I answered him
I'm interested in society but not in
sociology and this casual remark should
have inflamed Bob as you've heard
tonight he was one of the principal
architects of the sociological
profession as we today know it and I
think in a way his single influence was
as that great as the entire school at
the University of Chicago the
sociologists who preceded him by a
generation but he took my cocky comment
well because I think from his earliest
days he'd learned to look outward
intellectually rather than inward and to
me I think the formative experience in
having this kind of doubleness of vision
was the writing of that doctoral
dissertation Science Society in the
seventh in 17th century England it's a
book in which he applied mocks Faber's
idea of the ascetic Protestant ethic to
the flowering of experimental science if
you haven't read it in the last few
months
I just recall to you that it really has
two principal thrusts one is about the
accumulation of empirical knowledge as
as a way of doing science and the other
which I found so striking and still find
so striking is the notion that
asceticism is necessary for the practice
of good science credible
provoking idea as John mentioned this
book created what we now think of is the
sociology of science but it also posed a
challenge to sociologists to look beyond
their own normal boundaries and to get
out of their comfort zone I think Bob
was doing that throughout his life I
think it's fair to say that Bob cared
for his reputation as a disciplined and
disciplinary sociologist still he was
most intellectually aroused when he did
something that destabilize the common
sense of sumption of his colleagues and
that to me is a non specialist in the
sociology of science it's something that
I experienced again and again in reading
him he takes common sense and makes you
think well I didn't really think that
that was what was what was involved in
there but I want to say in my footnote
tonight just something about this
doubleness as it applied to his life in
New York and specifically to Columbia
University something I talked with him
over the end with Harriet over the years
about quite casually and I just like to
summarize to you one aspect of what we
talked about it's probably hard for many
of you who are young to understand the
pervasive anti-semitism
that pervaded American academia in the
1930s and even into the 1940s this
prejudice was not the Nazi kill the Jews
sort rather the lighter sort of English
press prejudiced too many Jews about our
distastefulness
sort of prejudice which appeared in TS
Eliot's poems and essays of this period
American Jews had trouble in becoming
students at Ivy League universities and
great trouble getting jobs at them now
Columbia was no more or less
anti-semitic during the easiest than
Harvard and Yale the Columbia was in New
York City home to tens of thousands of
poor talented young Jews with an
academic bent and their numbers swelled
by tens of thousands of European Emma
grace that generation older than me had
to figure out how to deal with this
anti-semitism my friend Lionel Chilean
was much more an intimate friend to me
than Bob dealt with it by imagining a
kind of fallback position he set for
himself when he first became an academic
he would become an editor and a
freelance writer if his life in academia
were to be blocked and particularly if
Columbia proved too hostile an
environment for it
Bob had no such option as there was then
not much of a free market for
sociologists nor is there now like many
many other Jews he changed his polish
name when Jung to the Anglophile moniker
that he carried most of his life and for
most of the people who did this this
name mask frequently fail
to to be protective Bob did not hide
behind this mask and it's something that
I found very moving about him he
defended colleagues overtly Jewish
colleagues like his great friend and
paul lazarsfeld and many others at
Columbia and he was a stout critic of
unearned wass privilege mertens
generation came to love Columbia as an
institution to the exact measure it
became a meritocratic university rather
than a perk for both dim and bright
wasps trilling Shapiro III Robbie and
Merton all saw this happen in the
nineteen late 1940s 50s and 60s they
made a home for themselves here they
were the university's meritocratic was
one reason why the who left upsets of
the late 60s at Columbia and so
disturbed them and it was particularly
from from Trillium Shapiro but I think
Bob too and why that activism left a
more discordant trace than it did at
Harvard which had little real connection
to Cambridge as a city but Merton being
Merton he could also see beyond the
local the disorders of his local home
and look at these conflicts and sized
them correctly
he had a scientists curiosity in fact
love about why things happen and this I
think he applied to the great post war
drama of Columbia but simply he kept his
school
in a way robert merton story at Columbia
has been played out generation after
generation in American academia
african-americans have succeeded
reans and Indians have succeeded
african-americans in making beachhead
landings on Ivy League territory we
might think that universities have
become more hospitable to these later
landings rather than reacted as though
they had been invaded which was very
much the atmosphere that Bob and Lionel
felt when they first came to Columbia in
my views not quite correct this happier
story because social class now play
something of the role that religion or
race that religion played in Mertens
time as a barrier I think that's felt by
white working-class young people so not
a barrier not so much now of outright
rejection as feelings of not belonging
here of being out of place which is also
today's story of New York City of course
it's made of the white working-class
kind of foreign body in a place
dedicated to success and wealth and I
think what was very sensible to this
that this was not a problem that was
going to be solved by elite institutions
the problem would be mobile and so I
think it's proved to be mobile from
religion in his generation to class in
our own time now there are many other
things to say about Robert Martin's life
and legacy and in this footnote I've
just touched on his doubleness only
because it seems to me an exemplary way
of handling the intellectual problem of
narrowness on the one hand and the
sociological problem of exclusion on the
other in Greek we use the term so for su
my heart's a chance late it indicates a
balanced state of conduct which
navigates between rigidity and disorder
or between desire and fear it
substitutes for these polarities
curiosity poll that he had begun
Anglophile that he seemed to become
Merton was really I think a classical
Greek in temper it's a good value to
celebrate and celebrating him as his
hundreds birthday years
I have no doubt that Bob would have
liked to have been a classical Greek now
we turned to Steve my old friend Steve
Stigler who was Ernest to wit Burton
distinguished professor Distinguished
Service professor of statistics at the
University of Chicago Steve is not a
standard-issue statistician it's true
that he has command over all the
esoteric skills that his field has
developed his research and collegial the
collegial recognition he's received
attest to that but he said historian of
statistics which is an odd thing having
written on the reception of
quantification in the sciences and the
history of statistical ideas his impulse
is to follow his quite unconventional
interests wherever they take him for
example in the study of anomalies in the
fossil record a finger prints or of 18th
and 19th century lotteries about which
he probably knows more than anybody else
and their role in forming public
attitudes towards risk he is also the
formulator of stigler's law stigler's
law holds that no scientific discovery
is ever named after its original
discoverer never one to let a good
opportunity for irony passed by Steve
named Robert K Merton as the discoverer
of stigler's law thereby making
stigler's law exemplify stigler's law he
and Bob were co-authors and had an
incredibly active correspondence
I had the sense that the rate of their
Changez increase geometrically with the
onset and development of email Steve
Thank You Harriet it's a pleasure to be
here it's a labor of love to come east
to talk about Bob Merton and listen and
more importantly listen to others I come
with a little different perspective than
the others they all have different
perspectives I come as a data point will
be statistical about this I'm going to
report on that data point and tell you a
little bit about my experiences with Bob
and show you a few pictures things that
you might encounter should you take the
trip to the archives and I can't imagine
a better way to spend a weekend now my
first encounter with Bob was not
personal it was by mail and it happened
in 1973 my close colleague and friend
Bill Kruskal had noted that I in the
years that I had just received tenure
and come to a visit at the University of
Chicago from the University of Wisconsin
and I had done what many people who get
tenure do is I'd taken the freedom that
it gave to celebrate by exploring into
different areas areas that I would not
have gotten tenure for for example like
the history of Statistics and I had
written a paper and in bill who knew Bob
reasonably well said send it to Bob
Merton now I was a little bit uneasy
about that I knew enough about the
history of science then to know that
when you get outside of when you get
outside of your own field and come in as
a as a outsider as I was in the history
of science you're not always treated
kindly on the scale of possible
reactions condescension is at the top
and but I sent this this paper off to
Bob and within a week or so I got
my first letter from Bob Merton it was
dear mister Stigler at the beginning and
by the way I put these up not in the
expectation that you'll really be able
to read them this is this is
illustrative dear mr. sticker well you
like my paper and he I think he picked
up on the fact that it was that I was
having fun with some of the things while
it was a serious discussion some of the
things I was talking about and and this
was a real boon to a young man who was
treading in dangerous territory at least
as far as any future career might go and
I must say that I very much appreciated
it and there was a brief correspondence
very short one that followed this not
much things were pretty quiet for a
while
after that was in fact when I got one of
gene
Garfield's requests to print postcards
asking for more reprints two copies of a
reprint and I responded and and it
wasn't too long I guess the color got
washed out a little bit but that right
hand side is the is I think the first
official yellow Columbia stationery
piece that I got a letter in 1976 but
over these years the these first few
years the correspondence was was it was
usually short and and it gave me no hint
that in the next 30 years the last 30
years of Bob's life I would receive
close to 200 letters from him going in
lengths up to 8 pages I've never got
close to the the bud Balin standard and
and in that these letters would lead us
into such interesting by ways as tracing
arcane phrases in the correspondence of
Isaac Newton to counting the number of
Grand Slams according to what position
in the batting order the hitter was
as an example of social structure in
action
well the slow start had an interesting
twist though in 1978 in I think April of
1978 one of Bob's students Tom Guerin
wrote to me and asked me would I
contribute to a second Festschrift from
people not in sociology a second Fester
if for Bob Merton now this sounded so
silly to me I haven't yet told you but
to this point I had not met Bob
we had never personally met and here I
was being asked to contribute to a
festering of someone I knew through a
few fugitive notes in the mail admired
him had read his pieces thought he was
thought he was wonderful but but he
still was a distant person in my life
and I thought about it for a while and I
got an idea
and I said yet to Tom yes I would do it
and in September of that year I
September 14th I sent a draft with Tom's
permission this was not to be a total
surprise to Bob a draft to Bob on
October 4th I got a letter and this was
the 8th page letter I touched a nerve he
very much appreciated what I was doing
he understood and commented on the fact
that what I was doing was not just some
fun in games but it was at heart really
a serious piece on the sociology of
science but it was a serious piece where
you could have fun and he remarked that
he felt the same way about on the
shoulders of giants that that was one of
his most popular books in some ways but
it was not a just fun and games it was
serious socially ought sociology of
science of an extraordinarily high order
and that is why he was so proud of it at
the very end he exploited multimedia by
taping on a cartoon which I'll magnify
from genes current contents in 1978 that
Harriet had just delivered to him that
day from her study they were out I'm not
sure they know they were not the center
remember this broad can I've got a
disease named after me you've only got a
syndrome well this is the first of
probably two dozen cartoons that I got
on a similar vein over the next few
years not all from Bob well the the next
story and I'm not going to tell too many
the hour grows late the next story that
I want to tell involves a sequence of a
set of correspondence that developed in
the early 1980s and and it was centered
around a particular building at the
University of Chicago Chicago and looked
from the 59th Street side at the at the
social science tea room there's an
archway that comes out for it it's in
this picture it's not particularly
readable but there's an inscription and
stone around the the bottom of below
though just below the windows that says
when you cannot measure your knowledge
is meager and unsatisfactory Lord Kelvin
those now that that inscription was
placed there by William Fielding Ogburn
who was in charge when the building was
built in 1928 was in charge of of what
inscriptions would would go he picked
this is essentially the motto for social
for modern social science but if you
look at other parts of the building
you'll find fascinating other examples
on one high freeze there is a Smith
Marsh on calculator the ultimate in
computational power there is also a
caliper for measuring scalps and and
there's a book so that so there's a
collection of things around and this
this statement is one of them well the
reason that this came into a
correspondence is that David sills
was a good friend of Bob's and and mine
wrote to to Bill Kruskal I believe that
Ken Pruett was was going to be quoting
Kelvin and this canid been at the you
know at the University of Chicago he was
going to quote this statement of Kelvin
and his honor in his annual report and
is it true that when this statement was
put up when you cannot measure your
knowledge as meager and unsatisfactory
is it true said David that after this
was stated as he'd heard that Frank
Knight had said and when you can measure
your knowledge is still meager and
unsatisfactory and this set off a chain
of letters between mostly David and I
initially sent a letter to both Bob and
to a bill Kruskal there were my father
was consulted on this and reported that
no that wasn't Frank Knight that that
was Jacob Viner and in that in fact
Frank Knight had had a different write
post namely that when you cannot measure
measure anyway but but but so this
correspondence was going forth and and
in the process Bob produced two fairly
long and magnificent letters the two of
them here the first was addressed to
bill and David query one what words of
Lord Kelvin are actually inscribed on
your building he asked a question of
some interest as it turns out and the
third the other one was to build David
and Steve now it turns out and I
discovered late later in this
correspondence
that that question what exactly is
inscribed has some serious meaning those
asterisks are represented on the stone
as flowers little rosettes and and in
going into the archives at the
University of Chicago I discovered that
they were put there in order to because
they are really ellipses they represent
dropping words out so that kelvins long
statement will fit and will fit on the
stone this is a long statement to
inscribe and Ogburn was bound and
determined that it would go there
well me to write a context for it in
that we could try submitting it
somewhere and and I did that oh I can't
remember this would have been October of
1978 I sent Bob and David my first draft
which is on the left there a a meager
quest for satisfactory knowledge and Bob
replied with another long letter which
did not make it into the subsequent
correspondence which was we heard him
out of his an editor he was actually
quite gentle on this occasion he did not
have much to say about the prose that
join the different segments he did take
my rather in adroit title and replace it
with another one you'll see in my the
red arrow there is my Edition not part
of his letter that says the Kelvin that
gave me
paper was to appear namely the Kelvin
dictum and social science and excursion
into the history of an idea it was great
fun and and it was not merely fun in
games although it was that - now the
correspond my correspondence with Bob
continued over several years it reached
a peak from the late 80s to the 90s
there were over 200 full-size letters I
got in that period but a lot of small
notes that came a lot of marked up
manuscripts that he sent to other people
all sorts of good things in the in 1991
he started using the fax machine which
is not good for archival material I must
say and in 1996 he started using email
now I'm not sure that that sped things
up the faxes came pretty fast the
letters came pretty fast but but the
emails once printed out became a little
more archival now if you were to visit
his correspondence here's what you would
find this is just an example of some of
the things people were speaking of I
wanted to give you some examples you can
see that a triple e marked up manuscript
on the left as he would this is actually
a page of something I'd sent him he
marked it up sent it to some other
people he then took that marked it up
and sent some other people and then he
marked it up again and sent back to me
he edited editorial remarks on one of my
letters if you look on the bottom left
it may not be too readable but one of
his stamps is there the one that says
error and it's unusual because it's
pointing in his own work he was calling
attention to the fact that he had
mistakenly in the letter that we'd
already published them referred to Lord
Kelvin as a Mancunian as as from
Manchester and and that was not true and
he was chagrined to discover later that
that was the case
you can see this this is what
correspondence with Bob was like if you
go into the correspondence you're going
to find all sorts of things you'll find
Bob's 1969 advice to an undergraduate
who had asked him how do you avoid
prolixity and Bob took a long page
before he even began to address the
subject you'll find EB Wilson's story of
how LJ Henderson 4 was first alerted to
Pareto's work on sociology by wheeler
and in part that was wheelers attempt to
repair a character deficiency in
Henderson you'll find a history of
social barriers to women in science
you'll find an evolution of an amazing
variety of quotations such as as he
encountered when he and sales were
producing the social science quotations
and you'll find what George Sartain
really thought about Auguste Comte now
how did he do this now here I want to
reveal one thing that is not in the
archive this came by mistake to me in a
mailing that's one day at the Russell
Sage Foundation there are 20 some on 20
20 different people that he's going to
correspond to starting with his son Bob
and and it goes on and on I looked at
the web listing of his archive and
estimate that he must have had well over
a thousand correspondents who deserved
and received folders the number of
single examples would surely double that
if one takes the usual analyses of these
sorts of things now I'm going to invite
you to go to those to those archives but
I wanted to leave you with one picture
it's the last picture a picture for my
last visit with Bob Riverside Drive
where we're toasting each other with a
glass of his favorite single malt scotch
whiskey the Glen drone ik this was
Saturday October 16th 2002 and so
were wood that I could toast Bob on this
occasion but we will all in a sense are
toasting him here
thank you I thought I would be the
cleanup hitter but I'm really concerned
about time it alright well one thing you
learn about speaking and teaching at
Columbia is that there's always fire
engines police sirens trucks rumbling
bye
so here it is again I begin with a
cautionary note counter to my
professional commitments to impartiality
to assessing ideas and evidence fairly I
have to declare that I am hopelessly
biased when it comes to Robert Merton
this holds for the man and it holds for
his work almost five decades of being
his student collaborator partner and
wife have only made me more so thus I am
absolutely not absolutely not impartial
when thinking about this evening's talk
I like Steve thought it should in some
way be related to the archive now this
archive reflects Bob's lifelong impulse
or compulsion to save his research
materials correspondence annotated
reading notes class notes memoranda
edited manuscripts calendars drafts
photographs and all manner of other
materials published and unpublished the
archive as I've learned by looking at
the finding aid available on the web
contains and I love this 218 point seven
four linear feet of files
more than a dozen small card boxes it
says an 18 large card boxes and short
there's a lot there
now given the archive size I could
hardly talk about it as a whole what I
thought I would do rather is to comment
a bit about this world of Bob which is
not so well known as his published work
is rather the unpublished Robert Merton
much of what he wrote never saw a print
now by way of context he was immensely
productive by whatever criterion one
might choose his bibliography lists 32
books and I say here one really can't
can't enumerate the number of books
because he was really given aside from
writing monographs to publishing in the
form of collected essays his big book
social theory and social structure
contains 21 such essays it went through
three different editions was published
in two condensed versions appeared in 15
editions and translations is this one
book well of course it depends on how
you count and what you want to
accomplish
I have no impulse to inflate Bob's
productivity I only call it to your
attention the bibliography also lists a
hundred and seventy seven papers not
counting translations Andry printings
twenty-nine introductions and four words
it does not it does not as you have
heard tonight include the countless
countless letters
but Bob wrote the number of book reviews
he wrote the hundreds of talks he gave
and what he estimated to be the thousand
or so manuscripts by other authors which
he edited and sometimes thoroughly
rewrote I know that he was really
skeptical about the importance of sheer
numbers of publications and judging into
influent intellectual influence and
rightly so but the numbers demonstrate
that he was no slouch when it came to
publishing and yet there is a lot of
unpublished work the files I know
show that at one extreme of the
unpublished Merton there is the catalog
of the numerous files he carefully
crafted of four papers he would write
that were on his writing agenda at the
other extreme are completed but
unpublished manuscripts put aside for a
variety of reasons often as Jonathan
said because he judged them not to be
good enough perhaps a limiting case of a
potential but unrealized publication is
a file containing a book manuscript
dating in 1978 it's entitled the
unanticipated consequences of social
action variations on a theme
bob was as his readers know preoccupied
with the notion of unanticipated
consequences that is consequences of
actions which not out which word not
only failed to achieve their attendant
goals but often produce their very
opposites this manuscript contains a
long opening essay bob wrote as well as
essays by four other authors another
paper is listed in the table of contents
by Raymond Budong
then already a great French sociologist
but it's nowhere in the file I called
this a limiting case because in addition
to the the MIRR Tony and manuscripts and
others there is an unsigned contract
from the Academic Press
it was close to publication but never
made it then there are the manuscripts
which were also close to publication
when it's called the professions which
was co-authored by William J good and
the other was usually referred to as the
housing study it hadn't gotten a title
yet this one contains the findings of
research Bob and his colleagues did when
the effects of social and spatial
organization on the residence of two
housing communities now earlier on the
continuum of completeness of manuscripts
are those he judged not ready but
clearly we're pretty far along these
include the paper that he and a son
Robert C Merton wrote called
unanticipated consequences the theme yet
again of the reward system in science :
there was always a colon and Bob's
papers titles a model of the sequencing
of problem choices actually bothers my
memory has it the paper was slated for
publication but it was pulled back by
both mertens because they thought it
needed more work then there are the
writings of the sort but Balin has
mentioned that Bob called the epistolary
genre the letters the writings which
were not originally intended to be
formal academic contributions but rather
as letters to friends
so hot sug on the shoulders of giants
was as bud said originally written as a
letter
another quotes letter that I camera came
across was written to Gerald Edelman the
neurobiologist and Nobel laureate
consisting of two parts this document
runs to a total of 40 single spaced
pages and deals with the intimate
connections between thinking as a genre
and speaking as a genre the letter
starts off with a riff on the
observation made by mrs. Moore and e/m
Foster's Passage to India where she
exclaimed how can I tell what I think
until I hear what I say this Bob called
the O L aphorism y ou L because mrs.
Moore was always described emphatically
as old and equally emphatic ly as a lady
so I spoil
I don't think Bob thought of it as
publishable others might disagree I
can't begin to guess how many other
manuscripts there are in varying states
of publish ability it's not a concept
but mentioned that's easily
operationalized I'm fairly sure though
that none of the unpublished work failed
to see print because it was rejected by
a journal editor or because Bob could
find no publisher interested in it he
would have mentioned it at at least
because he and I had both become very
interested in the fate of rejected works
but be that as it may he had
exceptionally complicated attitudes
about publication on the one hand no one
understood better than he did how
important publishing was in science and
scholarship without it private knowledge
fails to be transformed into public
nor did anyone understand better than he
that the only way to assert ownership
over ideas was to give them away the
only way to become the owner of an idea
is to give it away
and if priority is that issue
you better publish quickly as Bob said
as I have said Bob did not take his own
injunctions entirely to heart he decided
against publishing work others might
have considered publishable and he
delayed publication for unusually long
periods of time
he was as we have heard over and over
again a very tough critic of his own
work much tougher on his own work than
those numerous and highly annotated read
penned edited versions of other's work
his reference group though those people
whose judgments he respected and for
whom he wrote also had demanding
standards thus she set himself a very
high bar with the consequence that there
were few dull published but Pete papers
that were published under his name but
at the same time he did have
disappointed co-authors who had to
forego publication because the work
simply did not meet the standard now
given the choice the way to describe it
is that Bob clearly preferred to get it
right rather than to get it out he was
also aware that sometimes he overdid it
the book he and Eleanor barber wrote
called the travels and adventures of
serendipity was not published until 40
years after it was completed that's 40
years
the manuscript sat this is a prime
example of his reluctance to publish it
took the urging of two editors at El
Molino the great Italian publishing
house to women I might add to whom he
was devoted to persuade him to publish
it but even then publication wasn't
assured he was convinced the book needed
a new final chapter and I can testify
that he slaved over that final chapter
for over a year then he was stymied by
writing the introduction try as he might
he couldn't find any way of explaining
why the manuscript was being published
forty years late
how could he claim the work still had
value despite the long wait well it was
our friend James Shulman who I saw come
in who who saved the day James a
literary historian and then my Mellon
colleague and now president of art store
offered to write the introduction and
did so Bob loved it
thus the book was finally published in
Italian but that's another story then
there's a professions manuscript which
was written in the 1950s I mention it
because it was almost ready for print
just a couple of weeks ago I got a
letter from Marco Santoro who's a
professor of sociology in Bologna saying
he'd read it and that despite the read
the immense amount of recent work on the
professions in history he thought that
the book that the manuscript as it
stands is full of conceptual insights
and conceptual solutions to old
published of old puzzles and that it
should be published well should it I
don't know until I read it and get the
opinions of others able to judge it goes
without saying that I will try very hard
to keep in mind the what Bob would
said about the manuscript his
complicated set of attitudes about
publication extended to believing for
example that in that domain as well as
others there can be too much of a good
thing I'm going to skip over his
wonderfully satirical described
description of the malignant disease
known as the itch to publish the itch to
publish of course as he describes it has
three Latin names and he outlines the
etiology of the disease and its symptoms
it's quite clear that the itch to
publish is definitely an infra dig
disease and not one Bob wished to
acquire finally in this catalogue of
complicated attitudes about publishing
was Bob's loathing of deadlines for
writing in 1982 he wrote his self
Emancipation Proclamation copy put up on
the screen I do have a copy here and I
will read you just a expurgated version
of it having completed the last of 12
volumes to be written edited or revised
and some 20 articles representing the
full discharge of an inordinate stock of
moral not legal obligations which I
accumulated over the years I hereby
issue a self Emancipation Proclamation
in caps to remove at long last the
Albatross hung around my neck in the
form of ever urgent deadlines I declare
again in caps then I shall not again
agree to write revise or edit a book
deliver a public lectures contribute to
a symposium write an article or a book
review or incur any of the
they're like our obligations which so
easily accrue in the course of academic
life unless again in caps I have already
written revised or edited that book
prepared the lecture or written any of
the other sundry pieces referred to in
the antecedent paragraph and to give
spiritual force to this much too delayed
edict by identifying the hypothetical
limiting case I further declare that
should the editor of a festival in honor
of my oldest friend and closest friend
invite me to contribute a piece to that
altogether deserved honorific volume I
shall sadly but resolutely declined to
do so be it understood that the self
Emancipation Proclamation shall remain
in effect until the end of my days in
the fervent hope that I shall have
nothing but joy along with those
inevitable patches of suffering in my
work well did the proclamation always
work of course it didn't thirteen years
later as Budd mentioned Bob violated the
limiting and wrote a quite special
marvelous festive piece in honor of call
Paul called working with lazar spelled
but by and large it did limit liberate
him Bob could of course say no as he put
it he paid his dues he'd already
published a lot but most important he
had notes no shortage of good ideas of
his own on which to work
now again I'm going to bypass the list
of some 40 subjects that he published as
being worthy of attention in a later
paper
because again time does run short and
let me close by returning to the general
scene the public and the less public Bob
I'm reminded of an exchange I had with
Diana trilling some years ago said Bob
and Lionel were not close friends but
Bob and the formidable Diana did become
good friends and so did she and I we
gossiped a lot once she asked me to my
total surprise
whether Bob was as brilliant and
charming in private as he was in public
I didn't hesitate for a minute and
replied no he was not in private he was
in fact even better well by analogy does
the same hold for his writing is the
unpublished work better than the
published of course not Bob had taste
but sometimes his judgment failed some
of the unpublished work is likely to be
very good definitely worthy of attention
this of course is just a hypothesis one
that this wonderful new archive will
permit to be tested thank you
I want to thank Harry and the panel for
these wonderful reflections on the life
and work of Robert Merton the the excuse
that we can come together here tonight
of course is to celebrate his life but
we also have this wonderful archive that
has been processed by the librarians at
Columbia and is now available for
consultation by our students and
researchers it's noteworthy that the
what we call in our world the finding
aid the tool that used to exist in print
but is now searchable and findable on
the web is over 200 pages long in its
own right which speaks to the richness
and the beauty of the archive that we
have to work with and to thank Harriet
for all of her support over these years
that we've worked with this collection
we have made this special copy for
coming tonight I'm reminded as we've
heard so much about history of science
that when Albert Einstein came to the
United States he would never travel by
plane
he always traveled from city to city by
train and on one such trip the young man
came to collect the tickets and Einstein
realized he started digging in his
pockets and looking for his ticket and
the young man said dr. Einstein don't
worry don't worry you don't need to find
your ticket
but Einstein persisted and he crawled on
the floor and he lifted up the seat and
again the young man said dr. Einstein
please please this is unnecessary you
don't need to find your ticket while
Einstein stood up whirled around look
the young man on the I says young man it
is no longer a matter of whether I can
find my ticket it's a matter of where I
am going so I hope that
so on that note I hope where you will be
going perhaps is over to the sixth floor
of Butler library to the right the Rare
Book and Manuscript library on the sixth
floor will though be something to eat
something to drink and some of aspects
of the Robert Merton archive for you to
enjoy
so thank our panelists tonight